[Music]
that's right a kitkat bar but this isn't
about the kitkat itself
this is a story about the kitkat jingle
and how it was never supposed to exist
[Music]
my name is michael levine i'm a composer
and songwriter i have been writing songs
for 56 years now
i scored a show called cold case
i wrote a jingle for kool-aid that ran
for many years
but what everybody knows is the kitkat
give me a break jingle
bell
i got a call from an agency handling the
kitkat account
they had a campaign they already loved
and they just needed a throwaway song
something for the client to say no to
you can't present your client with one
idea you have to have something that
they're gonna buy and something they can
throw away so this was the throwaway
song
i came into a meeting with ken shuldman
who was the writer for the agency and he
gave me a couple of sheets of possible
lyric ideas
and we agreed on give me a break give me
a break break me off a piece of that
kitkat bar
i got in the elevator on the third floor
and by the time i got to the first floor
it was written
i had a very tiny budget for the whole
thing i literally couldn't afford to
hire singers so when we went to do the
actual commercial chris the producer
said well why don't we have the band
sing it
we did the vocal in one take and the
instrumental also in one take but on the
bridge of the song which originally went
you could keep it to yourself but it
wouldn't be fair cause that chocolate
crispy taste is love everywhere that was
a single voice singing and that was me
i ended up being the lead vocalist as a
result
[Music]
at that point the agency put both
campaigns with test audiences and
give me a break ended up being much
preferred by people
it did so well they didn't quite believe
the results so they tested it again
and it did better
at that point they decided to go with it
i was delighted that they picked it i
didn't have an inkling that it would
still be here 30 years later
i was told that hershey's had to build a
new kitkat factory to accommodate the
demand
[Music]
over the years as it's become part of
the american subconscious i'm proud to
have contributed to that and i'm
delighted by all of the new versions
that come out
mostly people make jokes about it
they're like oh come on michael give me
a break almost everybody thinks they're
being really clever when they ask me to
give them a break
[Music]
you